this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
reason today Liz wolf and I are joined
by Peter Meyer a former Republican
representative for Michigan's third
congressional district which is a
position once held by Justin Amash the
Republican turned libertarian
Congressman Myers now running for an
open senate seat in Michigan soon to be
vacated by Democrat Debbie stabenau and
we want to talk with him about his run
since he was one of several Republicans
ousted after voting to impeach Trump and
we want to know what it's like running
as that kind of Republican in the year
2024 among other things Peter thank you
for joining us I appreciate you guys
having me on sure uh you know uh we'll
start with your your campaign
announcement where you say that uh we're
in dark and uncertain times but that we
need bold leaders to usher in another
great American Century uh tell us more
about what you see as the darkness of
this moment and what you think it'll
take to escape that yeah I mean I think
if we look around the world we look at
our our the not neily the effects of US
foreign policy but the effects of a a
United States that seems to have receded
um and you know
the I mean terrorists and author Arians
that have kind of seized that moment um
the the barbarism that we saw that Hamas
uh you know conducted against Israeli
civilians and military personnel on
October 7th we have you know the
continuing grinding conflict in Ukraine
we have the ythis threatening to shut
down uh and and succeeding and and at
least discouraging a lot of
international Maritime Transit um I mean
even Pakistan bombing Iran right like
we're in a position where everything
seems far less certain uh where we don't
know what's going to happen where events
could easily spiral out of control and
then you look at a home front where I
mean some of the economic indicators are
more positive than they were a year ago
um but in the minds of average Americans
they're still thinking back to where
their expectations were for how much
they were going to pay for their
mortgage right if you have an adjustable
rate mortgage interest rate increases
have led that to double uh you know the
effects of inflation and some Supply
uncertainties have continued to see
elevated grocery prices that's something
that's very near to my heart coming from
a family grocery chain and our families
background and that's before you get to
those you know significant drivers of
cost of living challenges that have
remained elevated you know housing
Health Care education you know it feels
like in all of those
indicators American families that I
talked to families in Michigan they just
they feel uncertain about what the
future is going to bring younger
families or those who want to start one
are are nervous about how they're going
to be able to make ends meet and also
support you know raising children and so
there when I say dark and uncertain
times it's just a feeling that the
stability the foundation that many
people had relied upon that maybe they
had grown up feeling that that isn't
there anymore right when I talk about
you know a new a second Great American
Century you know how do we get to a
point where by 2050 we again feel that
the United States you know is not just a
superpower on paper but we feel that
sense of forward momentum that we have
policies at the federal level and we
have government officials that care a
lot more about what the results of their
policies are going to be you know than
just the simple fact of claiming credit
and and again to be able to look at at
you know objective demonstrable policy
outcomes in a clear and rational way um
rather than you know we're in the week
after the uh Senate um supplemental
which included this kind of grand um you
know border immigration reform
compromise you know feel like there's
there is there's an ability for our
governing officials to get down to Brass
tax but also to be held accountable for
the outcomes of their policy uh rather
than everything becoming a Blame Game
perpetually I mean I spent two years in
Washington um that is not a lot of time
but it was enough time time for me to
realize and understand that all the
problems I saw from the outside I wasn't
wrong in recognizing those problems but
so many problems are the consequence of
other problems that you need to you know
kind of peel back the layers of the
onion of dysfunction in Washington in
order to figure out how do we get down
to some core governing principles how do
we not just get in the position of
playing whack-a-mole when we have all
these events that come up and make us
feel like we're lurching from crisis to
crisis you know there's always going to
be areas of disagreement there's always
going to be division that's a reality of
politics but my God we should be able to
agree that you know crime is bad so what
are the policies that promote uh you
know safer
communities you know we want to have a
strong National Defense you know how do
we do that in the most costeffective way
and what should our International
engagements be that play to our
strengths rather than promote weaknesses
as I think a lot of our post 911 um kind
of military ventur ISM ended up
ultimately doing and and what is it that
we want to see the US's role in the
world be and how do we make sure that
you know we're continuing to build on
the areas of kind of core agreement so
I'm running for Senate because of that
desire to not only put you know family
concerns first you know an outcome
oriented mentality um but also to make
sure that that is not just a flash in
the pan idea it's not just oh this is an
easy talking point let's have a real
conversation about the systemic ways
that we can address this because I'm I'm
someone who enjoys the difficult art of
understanding complex systems and how to
improve them not somebody who you know
feels a high going on you know a cable
news show or or having a tweet you know
go viral I mean the the dopamine
addiction that I think has permeated our
society has permeated our politics uh
and that's how we are left in those dark
and uncertain times that's a good way of
putting it um the dopamine addiction uh
permea our politics I think that that's
pretty true the thing that I do want to
push back on is like are we actually in
exceptionally bad times you just talked
about the post 911 period and our
military adventurism then and the sort
of Uncertain foreign policy situation of
the early and mid ODS and then I'm also
thinking about the late 70s and early
80s as a time of extraordinary inflation
where many of the same things you were
talking about in terms of it being very
difficult to afford a decent life today
I mean families dealt with that then too
so are we really in uniquely bad times
right now I would say for the modern
moment uh it I think there's a feeling
of uncertainty that it that we probably
haven't experienced this Millennium
since um maybe the 2008 financial crisis
uh you know just that the amount of
sectors that have been that are
struggling and the amount of uncertainty
going forward now to your point and this
is where especially on the political
violence front I am you know quick to
emphasize in the 197 S I mean you had
hundreds of pipe bombs going off a year
you had you know domestic violence
coming from you know groups across the
political Spectrum uh the 1960s saw
periods of you know intense social
upheaval and unrest you know
assassination of a sitting president of
a leading presidential figure of you
know the the leading civil rights figure
of our time this is not the worst time
that the United States has been in right
I don't want to be a Cassandra around
that it's the fact that a lot of our
challenges we're dealing with in my view
are far more manageable and so if
they're more manageable then we don't
have a good excuse to just shrug away
from them or take a path of minimal
discomfort um you know rather than being
disciplined and diligent and focusing on
them so I I don't want to come across as
pessimistic but at the same time the
feeling I get when I talk to people the
the concern that sense of
unease again it's not it's not fear it's
not paranoia it's not you know Terror
like we've had moments of of extreme
profound you know fear in this country
that immediate post 911 moment you know
it's just a sense of I I want to feel
hope again that we're on a good
trajectory and it feels like everywhere
I look I don't see something that gives
me a reason to Hope yeah that makes a
lot of sense um I I do want to Pivot a
little bit and ask you just before we
get any deeper into this interview is it
weird running against Justin amamos I
mean I think to a lot of Libertarians it
feels like Mom and Dad are fighting or
very well may soon be fighting uh how
are you looking let's be clear he's uh
he's has not announced he's officially
running for Senate but he's launching an
exploratory committee which sounds laun
an exploratory committee yes so yeah
yeah is it
weird I certainly um you know I for the
readers awareness you know I or
listeners awareness I followed uh or
succeeded Justin amamos you know he was
in Congress he had uh left the
Republican Party he uh was you know
officially you know independent
libertarian uh during his final term or
the latter half of his final term in
office um um you know I've known Justin
for a while I you know solicited his you
know kind of feedback and thoughts on on
legislation because I think he's a very
thoughtful individual um again that
doesn't mean I you know agreed with
every kind of comment or um or
suggestion but I think he's somebody who
thinks deeply about issues and that is
is very much a rarity in our political
process um I'm not sure what he's going
to do you know whether or not that
exploratory committee will turn into an
actual finding filing um but
um generally speaking I think the more
folks who are engaged in our politics
and and putting forward you know
thoughtful principled ideas um is a good
one so I I'm did he give you a heads up
in advance though like were you shocked
by this or were you sort of aware that
this was happening you know I don't want
to get into any kind of private
conversations apart from just you know
the way in which a former um you know
member of Congress and a current one in
the same district might you know kind of
yeah look at overall you both you both
held that same district seat and you
both are kind of out of Step maybe in
slightly different ways uh with the
modern Republican party is there
something strange or about the district
to which you were elected uh that made
it possible for for both you and Amash
to hold that
seat I think a lot of people commented
you know there must be something you
know in the water in West Michigan we
have a fantastic water filtration
facility that takes it directly from
Lake Michigan near Grand Haven uh you
this was floride levels you were the
first to flate our water supply in
1946 used to be a fantastic tooth statue
in Grand Rapids they've moved it to
location um but you know J Ford
represented this District um you know
prior to being elevated to the vice
presidency uh you know before Justin it
was you know Vern aayers and Paul Henry
there were a number of officials who had
represented it who you know I think were
independent-minded in their own way um
and so I think it's you know very much a
close-knit Community West Michigan you
know can be accused on the outside of
being a little insular um but it's also
you know I it's a wonderful place it's
home um so perhaps perhaps there's
something in the water but I think it's
you know better to have you know members
who are in office and then maybe are
looking at things not just through not
just following the crowd I mean that's
the easiest thing to do in Washington is
to look up at the board and say where's
everyone else in my party going and you
know I'll just follow their lead um I
can say from experience and I'm sure you
know Justin would say the same thing um
it is far more difficult to say okay how
do I approach this issue in a consistent
way that can be defensible you know
rather than the inherent you know
reactionary polarization that you'll
usually see um you were you know for
taking that approach you were
unceremoniously booted out of your
congressional seat after ceremony to it
but okay okay uh semi ceremoniously
booted out uh after Trump backed your
primary Challenger in
2022 seemingly as retribution for your
vote against him in the impeachment
proceedings um which we'll talk more
about later but uh you gave a really
inter in farewell speech in the house
that I want to play a little bit of
because it lays out some of what you
were alluding to earlier about your view
of the current state of our government
um and I also think it raises what I
consider to be one of the most important
political issues of our time so let's
roll that excerpt from your 2022
Farewell Address to
Congress I rise today for the last time
as a member of the 117th Congress I do
not seek to dwell on the circumstances
of my departure although it does bring
to mind a few lines from yates's Second
Coming the best lack all conviction
while the worst are full of passionate
intensity perhaps it takes a cataclysm
like World War I to capture the naked
and malevolent Citi cynicism of our
politics Yates also well captured the
harrowing consequence of elite
ineptitude that precipitated the
slaughter of tens of millions Things
Fall Apart the center cannot hold mere
Anarchy is loosed upon the world I read
and reread those words while flying out
of Hamed carai International Airport
last August during the shameful end to
20 years of America's war in
Afghanistan what I saw on the ground
during that waking nightmare exemplified
some of the best of the American men and
women in uniform but it also reflected
the haplessness and incompetency of
American policymaking
the failure of our war in Afghanistan a
failure abetted by Decades of congress's
lack oversight of the president and his
Department of Defense to solve this I
push for Congress to take back its War
Powers to take back that constitutional
responsibility but even when it comes to
Congress asserting its own prerogative
this body has shown itself unwilling to
do its job the current budget
negotiations taking place on the other
side of the Rotunda also show a congress
unwilling to confront the very basic
task of passing a budget on time the
last time we had a budget passed before
the fiscal year started I was in second
grade when Congress is incapable of
solving problems of its own making how
can the American people have any faith
that we can tackle the problems arising
from the broader world what hope do we
have of outc competing China of winning
this coming Century if we can't even get
out of a mess of our own making we need
the best to regain their
convictions to set an example of what
cleare eyed leadership looks like both
at home and abroad we need to hold the
worst to account and reprise the moral
resolve that has led us through dark
times in this country many many times
before too many have sacrificed too much
for us to squander the opportunity
before us the opportunity to rise to the
challenge to this moment to set aside
Petty squabbles the opportunity to build
on the promise of limited government
economic freedom and individual liberty
the promise that underpins the American
dream so the war power stuff i' not seen
that in you know close to two years how
do how do you feel rewatching it like do
you feel like it all Rings totally true
today do you wish you'd hit any
different
points um you know those were the
moments was still aggressively
campaigning and petitioning and spending
a lot of time on the Senate side uh to
get the Afghan adjustment act passed to
try to get that into the you know ndaa
or into that Omnibus that was being
worked on um and you know because that
was a deeply personal kind of issue and
it was something that we were so close
to being able to get um ironically
enough and it got zero attention this
that um Afghan adjustment act which you
know would offer some
stability and kind of certainty for the
folks that you know had supported US
forces in Afghanistan that we had
evacuated some of whom you know were
still in the process of of kind of racu
evacuating and resettling uh to give
them you know some permanence as opposed
to the kind of temporary status many of
them are on um and it's an an Unholy
mess of of a kind of bureaucratic
conundrum therein uh and so that that
was I would say my my kind of main focus
um you know I don't know and I I hadn't
even kind of thought about it my my
campaign launch video hit a lot of those
same themes um you know just by you know
I probably should have done some of my
research and look back at you know those
words but you know were things I I
clearly and deeply believe and and think
are you know still very much ring true
um you know I think if you don't
have you know again a good balance of
power between the executive and the
legislative branch I think well if I can
just kind of step back there's a lot of
folks who think are our chaos in our
system right now is is a a product of
political chaos that because of how
chaotic our politics are you know our
government can't function and that's
what I thought going in today I I'm a
big believer gets the causality
backwards that the more our government
screws up uh that the more you know the
American people feel the consequences of
neft policymaking uh they more they
reach for you know replacements for
Alternatives um you know for
explanations for why that individual
when they got into office couldn't do
the things they promised to be able to
do uh so you know you this guy didn't
get the job done so we're going to vote
him out and send in somebody who's even
more emphatic that they'll do it and so
much of the challenge though is the
power has been stripped from many of
those offices in Congress you know
either Congress has has let the
executive take it has given it to the
executive or the executive has just you
know taking that over and so the basic
kind of mechanical function of our
government is broken
and that's where then you know you have
that promotion of extreme you know and
ever more chaotic politics if there were
fewer things the government was screwing
up you know there would always be people
who were dissatisfied but you know it'd
find less purchase you wouldn't be
fertilizing the same ground you know
that those kind of seeds of of mistrust
um you know can be planted in and so I'm
I think it's a it's a complicated things
you start talking about legislative
Supremacy and and Notions of of
subsidiarity and you know gener generic
Concepts um there it's challenging to
get that done not impossible but
challenging to get it done in Washington
because so many there's uh every
legislator will look at a policy um and
want need to see a very concrete upside
because the downside is always
theoretically exponential you know if
it's not broke don't fix it or if it is
broke um you try not to fix it because
no matter what you do if you get your
fingerprints on it you know you you
might uh be held to blame even if your
efforts were all well and good and pure
of heart and that's when I you know it's
easy to throw up your hands at that
challenge um but to me the art of
government is trying to say okay
politics is the art of the possible you
know how do you find ways in which you
can make you know a concrete lasting
effort it's a lot easier to do that if
you're getting at some of the structures
underpinning responses to issues than if
you're just getting distracted by the
issu at hand you need to deal with and
react to those issues but you also have
to be able to get out of that reactive
mindset to be able to put forward you
know a vision and also backwards plan
you know how do you get from that Vision
how do you get to that vision from where
we are you know what is that pathway
could you talk about that the structural
issue as it pertains to foreign policy
and the balance of powers because I know
it's something you have been very
focused on um that the something you
raised there is an attempt to make
Congress exercise its War Powers and
rebalance between con uh legislative and
executive branches which I think is
extremely important uh when we're
talking about the federal government
what are you hoping to accomplish on
that front to uh if you make it back to
DC yeah I think you need I approach a
lot of these with sort of a a policy
agnostic but you know Pro ESS obsessive
mindset um you know if you think about
War Powers often times it's you know
within the context of oh we need to end
this war and that's why we need to
repeal it I I mentioned the example of
the war on terror you know 2001
thereafter you know had that
authorization for the use of military
force that was passed shortly after 911
had that had a a sunset every two years
or or four years or six years um
probably six is too high but you know
two years three years five years
something within that band that's it's
not necessarily saying that nothing
would happen after that 5-year period
you know it's saying that there would
have to be far more frequent engagement
by the Department of Defense you know by
the you know National Security Community
with Congress uh and Congress would
because they'd have to cast a vote you
know senators and representatives would
have to be casting an affirmative vote
either in favor of continuing or uh in
opposition to continuing uh
military you
efforts they would be asking better
questions they would feel more of a
sense of ownership they would have to
articulate and defend they would but in
the process of asking those more
difficult questions the Department of
Defense would also have to sharpen its
pencils you our policy makers on the
National Security side would have to
more firmly articulate and align their
efforts with what they were saying right
this notion that if we're just going to
be hands off everything will be fine I
think is has become so detrimental and
so ruinous because you have sort of a
defense policy establishment that um
essentially looks at Congress as a body
to avoid I mean I there were a couple of
times where I would we'd be getting a a
classified briefing and I would say oh
my go than thank God we're finally
getting you know a briefing on on issue
x uh I've been waiting for a while and
then they turn around and realize you
know sort of um it was kind of like you
know you realize they're trying to sell
you a time share you know like it was
you know yeah we need your support on
you know this bill or this authorization
and so we're telling you big of a
problem uh is going on in this region
not because you should be aware not
because it should be informing you know
how you're approaching something but
because we're gonna have to ask you for
something and so if if the executive had
to ask Congress for more the amount of
transparency would be higher the the
feeling of responsibility among members
would be higher and you know I think it
things would just function better again
would that lead to less or more um I
think there's there's arguments being
made in in kind of either direction but
if we look at the strikes that you know
the president has just conducted
recently against the houthis against
Iranian back groups in um in Iraq in
Syria you know both are are picking from
a variety of different uh you
authorizations coming from the
Constitution whether it's um article two
kind of Defense powers of the president
uh in in a self-defense capacity or you
know article one authorities from
authorizations use of military force
that were passed in 2001 or
2002 again it it just is doing an end
run it is failing to engage and I think
it allows the American people to check
out because their representatives are
checked out um and that type of lack of
transparency of of lack of attention of
of lack of concern um I think ultimately
only Dooms those projects to failure
because then when people start to do pay
attention after something bad happens
you know they catch them M El up on 20
years in in the span of a you know
two-minute Tik Tok video and that's
probably not going to be conveying an
accurate I mean I could I could I could
tell from that speech that your
experience serving overseas you brought
a certain you you had a you're almost
like personally insulted by the way that
these wars have been conducted over the
past couple of decades like what what is
it that this sort of I don't know half
half Hazard or just like rubber stamping
type approach why is that particularly
insulting and damaging to the people who
serve in the military yeah it just shows
a disregard right it I think you know by
way of background I was in Iraq as a
soldier doing intelligence operations in
in you know uh 2020 sorry 2010 and 2011
and then I was in Afghanistan uh as an
NGO conflict analyst for humanitarian
Aid community so you know no uniform no
weapons neutral living on the economy uh
from 2013 to 2015 and you know I think
in both of those conflicts we found
ourselves with allies of convenience
that just looked at the us as an entity
to exploit um we didn't necessarily have
any specific strategy or objective or or
goal we were going towards or if we did
it would change frequently enough that
you know what we were doing was never
aligned towards any specific specific
intent um you know that notion of a
self-licking ice cream cone and the
reality is that the entire time you're
there I mean there's a risk that you're
undertaking American Service members are
dying um you know again I don't
reflexively say oh you got to bring
everyone home or there's no scenario in
which we should be in some of those
areas but our policy makers sure as H
need to articulate why those risks are
being undertaken to what end you know
what are those terms um and and how
often would those be re-evaluated
because I think the majority of the war
on terror or at least our kind of post
911 moment has been you know this linear
sense of Engagement where it's like okay
we're either going to maybe some
sanctions then we're going to have some
air strikes maybe a special forces raid
uh maybe you know the Marines will go in
and be you know temporary or maybe we're
going to hold and build with kind of
large conventional forces and it's like
okay well to to what end what's our goal
yeah and have our efforts helped achieve
whatever that goal is but you can't even
measure if they've been effective if you
don't have a consistent goal or you keep
changing it and again lives hang in the
balance civilian lives are lost military
service members lives are lost and the
taxpayer is footing the bill for all of
that yeah it's been catastrophic on so
many different levels um I I I do want
to bring us to a couple uh of your other
policy the the other
policy priorities that you seem to have
in this campaign uh and to kick off a
conversation about that I've got I did
pull a couple clips from your campaign
announcement that I think could give
your viewers a sense of the issues
you're running on uh in this first one
you talk about the importance of babies
of making more babies let's roll that
clip I'm Peter Meyer and I'm running for
US Senate and I want to let you in on a
secret most politicians are terrified of
the media of saying what they actually
think are proposing things that are big
and bold we should be making it easier
for people to get married buy a house
and just have more babies my wife and I
just had a son and I can tell you babies
need to be the vision for our future and
when those babies go to school parents
should never have to worry if their
children are guinea pigs in someone's
social experiment parents deserve a say
and choice that's why we need a regime
change in education we need to expel the
anti-semites and activists who are
poisoning young minds with hate we need
to hold University is accountable when
they Swindle students by hitting them in
their tax-free
endowments so you're talking to a couple
of young parents with young kids right
now and you know neither of us are
voting in the Michigan Republican Senate
primary but we're in the age stage of
Life demo that you're kind of speaking
to there um what is why why is making
life better for parents top of mind for
you I you can obviously look at our
demographic issues that we're facing as
a country but a lot of this I just
boiled down to the simple question um
how are what is our government doing to
make the American Dream Within Reach
what are they doing to you know further
complicate things and I will start off
by saying the number one frustration I
have is when every policy maker or
legislator or politician reacts to a
problem with you know a new set of
legislation or a new law as opposed to
from the get-go saying what are we
currently doing that is either helping
or that is hurting and if it's helping
maybe do more of it if it's hurting
let's stop it because the easiest thing
for the government to do is to stop
doing things that are being you know uh
demonstrably you know uh ineffective or
that are making the problem worse that's
a lot easier to do than proposing
something new that's uncertain you know
so in my mind you know when it comes
down to our our role as you know policy
makers the role of our legislature and
specifically the role of our federal
government um is to be able to get out
of the way you know to resist that urge
to always tinker and Fiddle you know
when when you look at our housing policy
in particular you know that is where a
thousand good intentions you know have
been the individual Brinks bricks in a
road that has led State straight to an
unaffordable hell in our current market
um you know that that is geographically
dependent but all across the board that
is a massive major strain so you have
more folks who are unable to afford to
buy a home you know are kind of locked
into renting aren't building up you know
a base of assets um or postponing uh
having families for financial reasons
and I'm very skeptical of what the
government can do in an affirmative
sense but starting with getting the
government out of the way I I've yet to
have anyone who's pushed back and said
oh that won't work you know reducing the
regulatory burden making sure that you
know uh I mean on the educational side
again this is largely a a sto state and
local issue but at the federal level
there are all of these strings attached
there are these compliance and and
Reporting incentives that both raise
costs but also can be used to tweak in a
way um our education system away from
sort of again demonstrable objective
outcomes that we can come to an
agreement on and turn something into add
an inflection around a a socially
benevolent or or you a socially tinged
policy uh that you know you kind of wake
up and look at that San Francisco School
District that uh gave a quarter million
dollars of of taxpayer funds to you know
quote unquote woke
kindergarten and from just a parent
standpoint they step back and say I you
know maybe there's a conversation there
that you know should have taken place
with those parents you know but the idea
of of again removing so much individual
consent or individual notion from every
single Dynamic of a a government that
continues I think oftentimes not in a
malevolent way but just out of a sense
of of of huous and arrogance to presume
they know better and and drive um or
incentivize outcomes that again stray
from objective standards and into the
realm of you know I called it in that
kind of someone social experiment I'm
very much in respect the libertarian and
non-aggression principle you know you
should be very very humble in
understanding you know who can do what
our technocrats need to be humble our
government policy makers need to be very
humble in appreciating what the
unexpected outcomes of something may be
because if you don't and you are are
Reckless and arrogant you know there's
going to be a reckoning and that will be
socially challenging I don't mean
Reckoning and a um in a sincere like you
know catastrophic sense but I'm have a
Dutch background I mean Reckoning um in
Dutch D Reckoning that's the bill you
know the bills come in due um you know
we're going to have to pay for one way
or the other so let's have some humility
on the front end so we're not surprised
on the back end well so a few months ago
reason ran a cover Story by one of our
colleagues um that throws a little bit
of cold water on the concerns about
fertility rates I think that this is an
interesting area that we've actually
engaged with a fair bit on this show
because there's a lot of disagreement
among Libertarians um Libertarians tend
to support by and large um government
being as values neutral as possible many
Libertarians support the removal of any
sort of um tax advantage uh for married
couples um a lot of Libertarians tend to
basically say government needs to get
out of the way and frankly not be
concerned with how people are living
their lives or whether or not they're
forming families or on what timeline
there are some Libertarians and I would
probably count myself among them that
are a little bit more concerned about um
what our fertility rate looks like over
time and whether or not we're going to
be emulating Japan with their sort of
gray population uh and like inverted
pyramid how do you look at these thorny
questions like how would you convince a
a skeptical libertarian or a Libertarian
who's antagonistic to your idea that
baby making is important
what would you say to them if you had
you know 30 or 60 seconds to make your
case yeah I would certainly agree that
the government shouldn't be in the
position of of of promoting a specific
agenda and again that's where I come
back to policy makers also being very
humble because a lot of well-intentioned
policies um especially in probably
including in the pronatalist camp can
lead to outcomes that are are far from
intended so
a again boiling down to that
affordability question um you don't
achieve higher affordability uh and the
you don't achieve that through you know
um subsidies that can have a temporary
impact but eventually the market will
adjust and it becomes a dependency you
get kind of bomb almosts cost disease
that will come into play very quickly uh
you know the fact I would say is there
are some things that I think are
relatively objective social goods that
if the government is maybe not in a
position to be able to affirmatively
promote or where they're promoting a
policy could have negative effects it
should be doing everything it can to
make sure that it is not uh operating
contrary to that social good but why
does it matter at all in the first place
like why does it matter that we have
children running around and attending
schools and on the playgrounds that we
pass by versus you know a situation like
Korea or Japan's like who cares oh I
mean if if you anyone who's interested
in the long-term fiscal sustainability
the US should care anybody who wants you
know the us to continue to be a growing
and and thriving country should care um
you know our our social security system
was set up when there were 2.1 workers
uh sorry um you know 14 workers forever
retiree and now the ratio is is 2.1 to
one like at some point the math just
kind of runs
out I think again I I I'm very skeptical
of the heavy-handed role of the
government what it could do um in in
terms of affirming those policies and
where I say the number one thing is if
we agree that this is good we should be
able to agree that the government
shouldn't be doing anything to prevent
that so the more we peel back those
layers to me that should be a place
where you can reach both bipartisan
consensus and where it's aligned with
just general limited government
principles I find myself generally uh
torn on this issue so I definitely
appreciate uh the ability to in a sense
play Devil's Advocate and uh promote the
libertarian side that's maybe more
antagonistic to your thesis though I
mean I have a 16-month-old right like I
am extremely soft on the issue of B and
think that we should probably all have
as many of them as possible Zack you
were going to jump in well oh there's
just one other policy issue I wanted to
touch on with you something that jumped
one other thing that jumped out to me
from that ad which is an issue that's
very important to Michigan voters I
presume uh where you're talking about
manufacturing and competition with China
so let's roll that
clip
do you know that China is graduating 10
Engineers for every American engineer
this is not a time where we can afford
to play nice I'm a free market guy but
if corporations want favors from our
government then they better be investing
here if we're going to have to pay for
electric cars then we better be building
them in Michigan not Mexico and we
should be using Supply chains that are
American not
Chinese so what I heard there was I'm a
free market guy but but what Peter but
what what could you just explain that uh
a little bit further for us yeah I mean
the reality of our current economic
climate is you know we
are we are free market with a heavy
asterisk around so many different areas
where you know either from uh you know
heavy-handed federal policy or or
regulatory job boning or you know just
objective pieces of legislation that
have been passed you know Washington is
picking winners and losers we are making
determinations plenty of companies come
to DC for handouts the ideal world is to
peel that back and to get away from it
if we have this world and I want to deal
with the world as we have it I would
like to see us get to a world uh where
we do have you know far less uh Federal
policies that are creating a more
challenging business environment
especially those that are not readily
defensible on grounds of of safety or um
or you know just objective environmental
components but are around more nebulous
you know goals um you know strings
attached to dollars that again then
distort what should be a very simple
profit or loss you know business
equation and become one where there are
you know um you know regulatory capture
of a a sector uh where as we see in in
on my state of Michigan right now you we
have made so many parts of our state
regulatory apparatus burdensome that the
only companies who are coming here are
those that were forking over hundreds of
millions of dollars to um incentivize
them to come and at that point they you
know they're oftentimes only the
companies that don't want to locate or
won't be received well anywhere else so
many of them end up having um you know a
Chinese economic ties so I think this
this is where untangling that web is
essential but where we have that web
um having some very clear understandings
of of what is our where are we opening
up liabilities with our dependence on
Chinese Supply chains I'm certainly not
somebody who has any issue if our pool
floaties are made in China but you know
if the majority of our prescription
Pharmaceuticals are coming from outside
the country and in the event of you know
A disruption to global trade or
international shipping or anything we
saw along the lines of Co now we're in
real trouble right I think it's about
reducing those vulnerabilities
appreciating those vulnerabilities and
not just having a reflexive um what I
think we've seen all too often a
reflexive notion and even incorporated
into American policy that ends up
hurting our own ability we can go from
by American policies to the Jones act to
a handful of other places where you can
just align what the stated intent of the
policy was and demonstrably show that
the policy is not reaching it and
there's an incuriosity legislatively to
address it um you know that worries me
and that's where I'm highly suspect of
affirmative policies but when we're
looking at how our system is being
managed at the moment being very clear
that we should not be permitting or
accepting you know uh you know taxpayer
dollars that if they they maybe
shouldn't be going there in the first
place but if they are then those should
be focused domestically
if we have these policies then we should
be promoted in such a way that is doing
minimal damage while we still have them
I think you win the reason drinking game
um anytime Jones Act is brought up we
all have to take a shot this is like a
huge uh pet issue of pretty much
everybody on staff at reason over here
and I think it's a little bit of this uh
libertarian uh bat signal that we sort
of give out to each other but but again
just connect a policy with an outcome
right yeah absolutely intent was to
support the domestic maritime you know
industry and specifically the
construction
industry then why do we have the lowest
tonnage you know of of ships built in
the US than you know we've had in over a
century right
so I'm yeah I agree with you completely
you know you know you're you're known as
one of the few Republicans who voted to
impeach Trump for his behavior on
January 6th in fact this is the way that
the New York Times is characterizing
your Senate run petete Peter Meyer a
republican who voted to impeach Trump is
running for Senate um you know uh given
what the GOP has become though we've
seen this Glide path to the nomination
that Trump is on how big a problem is
that for you in terms of being viable in
a Republican primary I frankly don't
think it's much of a problem um I think
there's I was just having this
conversation earlier there's an
interesting Dynamic where from and I'm
not labeling reason as sort of media
quote unquote you are obviously a media
organization but in like the broader
media narrative everything can be
reduced down to these um you know these
kind of polar Dynamics right you're
either you're Pro or anti you're on one
side or the other um you know I never
you know called myself somebody who was
you anti- Trump or or never Trump um I
took serious issue uh up to it including
obviously voting to to impeach the
former president for his actions on
January 6th um I thought that that was
you know worthy of both uh condemnation
and also worthy of a adjudication in the
Senate um because that was a dark and
shameful day and the American people
deserve to hear uh you know the facts
presented and for the president than
former president to make his case um you
know the reality I think of so well the
reality that escapes so much of our
politics and and where it becomes
challenging is you know I don't accept
that you have to be all one thing or all
the other that you know you're in either
the the the black box over here or the
white box over here um I try to call
balls and Strikes I try to be as honest
a broker as I can of not excusing
something that I would have condemned
had it been uh somebody of the opposite
party doing and I think that's something
I grew up you know despising politicians
for watching John Stewart back when he
was is actually funny and seeing you
know him playing clips of a u of a
member of Congress arguing against you
know the 2-year prior version of themsel
on the same issue uh with the only
difference being you know who was the
president and they supported it when
their guy did it and they opposed it
when the other guys you know other
person's guy did it I think that leads
to the cynicism we have and so that's
who I try not to be I try to have that
consistent approach try to call balls
and Strikes be an honest broker and you
know at the end of the day I can
honestly say I would vastly uh prefer
even you know maybe my least favorite
Republican candidate uh to a second Joe
Biden Administration um why were so many
of your colleagues such cowards when it
comes to the impeachment
vote there were certainly plenty of
folks who had
[Music]
um what I would say are kind of sincere
and reasonable objection
uh vast majority of folks will just and
this is not um this is not limited to to
that vote on almost everything it would
say well you know there's safety and
numbers where's everybody else going
I'll just follow suit um but to me
that's just the definition of like moral
cowardice right like when push comes to
shove they're not willing to actually be
leaders in any way and say and and and
assess the evidence in front of them and
say you know a lot of the stolen
election claims are fairly bogus they
can be adjudicated via the court system
in many way in many cases they
ultimately were and judges consistently
ruled that they were um not very
credible and the actual actions that
people took on January 6 were um pretty
abominable uh really an attempt to
impede the ability to appropriately
register you know people's political
preferences I'm sorry but like I I just
am I missing any anything or is that a
pretty clear-cut situation where there's
just an extraordinary moral cowardice
problem among Republicans right now oh I
mean you never I mean the the sort of
line is you never have to explain why
you voted no on something but you know
if you vote Yes somebody will always
find something to take fault you know
again I I had some colleagues who um you
know would would agree with everything
you said but would say well I you they
read the article of impeachment and they
were uncomfortable that it was alleging
a criminal action again not a criminal
process but that it didn't have a kind
of broader dereliction of Duty there
were actually Republicans who were
trying to work with Nancy Pelosi on
having a more limited article um who had
committed to voting in favor of it but
she said no we're going with what we
drafted U because her goal was to have
as few Republicans um in support as
possible
it I'm going to save a lot of that for
for a memoir but I mean the reality is
and again the way I look at things
um change the party you know change the
person who's doing it from somebody
who's you know on my side to oppose or
somebody who's opposed to me to being on
my side if that changes how I view the
action then my ethics are clearly only
situational and and I should find
something that I can be consistent about
you know there's going to be votes that
are shirts and skins right there's going
to be things that you know what is a
sticking point to you in the minority
you might be comfortable with if you're
in the majority or vice versa um but the
the sort of just
reflexive approach where it doesn't seem
like anybody actually believes anything
um yeah I I don't I don't abide that I
don't like that I saw plenty of it it
disgusted me I enjoyed quietly being
like now now you voted this way in the
you know effort to hold uh you know Air
Cold oring contempt but uh how how are
you making the distinction between this
um and to some of my colleagues credit
they would say okay honestly like I can
find you know two or three distinctions
but I don't really believe in it like
some of this just comes down to shirts
and skins I I want to Glide over the uh
what you said earlier which is that you
say that you would support even your you
know most disliked Republican over the
you know a second Joe Biden least
favorite your least favorite Republican
um so we can possibly put Donald Trump
into that category I don't want to put
words in your mouth but um what why is
that you know given
your sincere kind of principled and
moral objections to what went down
around the election What hap you know
the behavior on January 6 and post
January 6 and just these ongoing legal
cases hanging over his head what is it
that you know still makes that more
appealing than a second Biden term yeah
I I would
say to me the the two most pivotal days
in my time in Congress were you know
January 6th of 2021 and August 15th of
2021 when Afghanistan collapsed um and
my you
know both
were moments where I a lot of of folks
that I had thought better of or systems
I had thought you know had some
competency you know were really shown um
the shine was totally off you know both
of those respective apples you know one
in the domestic political side the other
you know in our our kind of incompetency
of our national security apparatus um
and the unwillingness of of a lot of
people to um you know gauge and and
react to appropriate
risks when but is it fair to lay the
disaster of the Afghanistan withdrawal
completely at Biden's feet I mean there
was a wasn't there a certain
inevitability that you know we were to
pull back there was going to be a
collapse of the government there and I
want to be very clear um you know I
think there was there was
a we could spend an hour on this the my
specific way in which I felt um you know
very much betrayed and felt like that
was sort of a betrayal by proxy of a lot
of the folks who you know hinged um on
us when Biden announced that he was
going to withdraw you know by then said
September 11th and then it was moved up
to September 1st um that was in April of
20121 um and I was supportive of that I
was supportive of Trump's effort to
withdraw we immediately had a bipartisan
group of us working in Congress saying
okay we still got a lot of folks who
supported us this special immigrant Visa
program what can we do to you know now
that we have a time frame now that we
have sort of a final clock that should
light a bit of a fire to to go and
process all this uh it was roadblock
after roadblock um those flights only
started leaving um I think the first one
was on July 29th uh and and it was 200
people a day um not every day and then
within two weeks the entire you know
kind of country collapsed and we were
left with the mass evacuation that we
had um we when I say we encountered
roadblock after roadblock some of it was
just bureaucratic incompetency making
sure everything goes through the inter
agency process yada yada yada uh and
there was also I think a great fear on
behalf of the Biden Administration that
the evacuation of you know Afghans which
was supported in a bipartisan way this
was very much not a controversial issue
um you know that that would end up
getting compared or Draw light to the
problems that we were having on the
southern border which even at that time
the Biden Administration was aware of
and were paranoid of of that becoming a
larger media Focus because they thought
it would be so politically damaging to
them or or raise uncomfortable questions
now you know that fear um that led to to
basically the you know evacuation of of
Afghans who had supported United States
forces that we had a commitment to
um that ultimately was really the
inflection point that tanked his
approval rating and so I I both have you
know a deep feeling of kind of personal
betrayal um from that um and and just
it's still kind of a knife in my gut
that I still feel is very sharp uh
combined with my overall long-term view
of what is going to be better for the
country
I think that overall where the root of
so much Social chaos and disorder is
going to come from um what will be the
number one exacerbating factor that will
certainly be capitalized to expand the
size scale and scope of federal
government to turn a ratchet in ways
that we can't ratchet back is if we
encounter significant and severe and
persistent economic uncertainty and
unrest that will make everything
worse I think the
that's where I come down to and Biden is
more likely to deliver that in your
opinion I mean I I would be very open to
someone making the counterargument um
you know when I what I saw in Congress
in terms of the administration ramming
through policies that even some of my
Democratic colleagues knew would be
economically harmful but they didn't
feel like they could stop or or have a
voice to say no um the the insane like
postco spending um
yeah I mean the American Rescue plan was
probably I think the consensus estimates
um at least three to four points or
sorry at least two and a half to three
points of the inflation that we saw
could be solely attributed to the 1.9
trillion coming out of that we're always
going to have some inflation just with
covid um you know I think there were
some well-intended policies that you
know I'm willing to give the benefit the
doubt on and then when you're passing
policies when there's very clearly no
economic imperative to do so um and it's
just just all sort of a partisan grab
bag uh you
know that that buck stops at the
president's office but the broader
Challenge and issue that we have I
mentioned sort of legislative Supremacy
you our executive branch is far too
powerful the fact that you know we feel
like if you elect the wrong president
the country is going to you know take a
nose dive a lot of that problem is
because of the office I think the Office
of the President is one of the most
dangerous institutions in the western
world right now because of how much
power um both through Supreme Court
decisions and through you know uh
legislative ineptitude incompetence or
um inattention has ultimately accured
into that office and that has that to me
is far more important than who the
individual office holder is and what
their policies are I sincerely
appreciate the argument that you're
making and the pragmatism that you're
talking about with regard to you know
how Joe Biden has actively made the
inflationary situation so much worse in
a way that harms people's budgets and
then that um incubates a certain amount
of you know political unrest uh that
stems from that I I I'm very sympathetic
to all of that but I'm still struggling
with this
fundamental idea that you know if push
came to Chef you would feel more
comfortable supporting Trump than Biden
uh in seeking another term I mean are
you concerned about Trump's co-opting of
the Republican the the degree to which
the Republican party has been totally
co-opted um and corrupted under Trump as
well as you know I mean you have been
such an Ardent voice against a lot of
the election conspiracy theory stuff um
how do we know that that's not going to
get worse in a way that fundamentally
threatens American democracy and our
institutions yeah I mean and this is
where I always try to be
you
know understand you know okay well what
let me try to have a consistent standard
again that that notion of being
consistent understanding the components
and depths of a problem you know the
numbers of democratic voters who viewed
the 2016 election as illegitimate were
the mirror image of Republican voters
who viewed 2020 as illegitimate um that
doesn't excuse you know Republicans
doing that and obviously the post 2020
election period was dramatically
different than the post you know 2016
election period but to me it says this
is a the problem that's underlying this
is more widespread right the violence on
January 6th and the violence that we saw
over the summer of 20120 again neither
excuses or or should allow anyone to
condone one while condemning the other I
think both are worthy of condemnation
and you know both may have degrees of
difference in various attributes but the
Common Thread is it was a a large group
of people expressing a frustration that
they felt could not be resolved within
the system so they engaged in activities
that were you know attacking the system
from without rather than working from
within so again my broader view is while
not you know condoning um you know
either is to say well let's look at what
is underpinning some of this what is the
problem beneath the problem because that
if we don't address it if we don't get
at some of those issues of institutional
trust if we don't have you know a a that
feels like it is representing everybody
that there are minimal incompetent
moments that are going to be highlighted
because with social media and the
internet is a lot easier to highlight
them if we reduce the amount of times
where someone looks at the government
and says what are these um trying to
swear less but you know insert your
profanity of choice guys
doing then maybe we can get to the point
where that temperature is is kind of
boiled down the challenge is you know
from one partisan position to the the
other it's well let me condemn all the
things that I can on the other side and
then find Convenient ways of
rationalizing my own so that's I think
that's yeah I think that's it's a really
it's a really important Point um that
there's a lot of the the degradation of
the norms and the institutions is coming
from the other side and it happens in a
more perhaps more subtle way than you
know Trump's blatant uh claims of
election fr and conspiracy like like one
one thing I'm I'm continually fascinated
and horrified by is the extent to which
Democrats and some of the hardcore
anti-trump Republicans who constantly
sermonize about how our H hallowed
democracy is in trouble if the mega
movement gains ground are actually
willing to prop up Mega candidates uh in
fact you know we know from the Wikileaks
emailed yeah I know what happened to you
and I want to talk about that in a
second
but like on the biggest scale it
happened the Wikileaks dump showed that
that was a strategy of the Hillary
Clinton campaign to push as much media
attention as they could towards Trump
they called it the pi Piper strategy and
yeah it happened in your election race
let me just pull up the uh New York
Times article on it uh Democrats Aid
far-right candidate against Republican
who backed impeachment that being you um
and they note that
$425,000 of
advertising uh went uh from democratic
groups went to your uh basically it was
a an ad that uh was kind of pretending
to attack your opponent but really was
just like highlighting all the
attributes that would be uh appealing to
a hardcore conservative so it's this
kind of like sneaky advertising in favor
of your opponent because they thought he
would be easier to beat in the general
and turned out they did beat him in the
general so their political calculation
might have been right but the the moral
calculation is what's more troubling and
interesting to me and what I'd like you
to comment on yeah and I mean to
me and just for the record so I lost by
my primary by three points right it was
not exactly you know a blowout um you
know ultimately I I take responsibility
for that loss but you know it was
I thought it was very rich the way that
you know like I would hear the Democrats
rail against you know what a threat
these guys are and you know at the same
time doing everything to boost right and
and that's where I am very much a kind
of pox on all House's mentality I think
it's um there's a sort of I think both
sides in something get a bum wrap
because it's often well it's fine if we
do this because they do it too and my
point is no like
everyone here has has some blood on
their hands in terms of producing the
moment that we're in um there may be
degrees of difference in terms of who's
done more in this case or more in that
case uh but ultimately both parties and
all folks are living in glass houses on
this so just you
know as a republican I want to be able
to condemn when you know mobs try to
intimidate lawmakers and that can become
a hard thing if I spent the whole time
condoning or making excuses for um you
know January 6th right like because
consistency matters to me and then
that's not going to say that I'm you
know there aren't places where I look
back and say oh well I probably should
have done this or how do I find that
thread you know I'm not going to pretend
to be perfect in that but that is my
aspiration that is my goal and that
stands in contrast to a a political
system who's I
mean the amount of times I've seen the
post and I've or somebody's comment and
I'm like I cannot tell sincere sinly if
you were being sarcastic or not because
I could I could find the rationalization
for you know a sincere interpretation of
this tweet or for it to be entirely
tongue and cheek because you
know like it's all unmowed right and and
again getting back to the beginning of
this conversation that feeling of like
um you know what actually matters who
actually believes something where where
are we actually going or are we just you
know all these whirling dervishes you
know spinning around and and staying in
the same place um I would just like to
be able to uh
affirmatively you know out or have you
know government officials you know folks
making policy affirmatively outlining a
position and consistently defending it
as opposed to you know well you're going
to forget about what I said last week so
I'm just going to you know adopt
whatever the flavor of the day is um
because you know our again our attention
spans may not be long enough for anyone
to recall it and anybody who points out
that inconsistency you know I'll just
call them a nerd and and somebody who
you know is you know if you're
explaining you're losing or whatever and
and just drive forward
it's I'm sure there's some H happy
topics we can we can kind of wrap up on
but but that that broader Trend and and
you know this week and the Supreme Court
there'll be the uh the case about
whether or not Donald Trump can be
thrown off the Colorado States the
Colorado ballot the main ballot 14th
Amendment argument that we've covered a
little bit before on this show yeah no
and and I mean the the thing I just I
want to grab some of the folks who are
advocating for this and saying like well
um so what would you what would your
defense be if that same argument was
applied to you you know and it's always
this is different or or Trump is unique
or or X or Y or Z it's like okay but um
you know that's a value judgment you're
you're saying that you're setting a
precedent How would would you like it if
that was you know used against you or
what what would you say and if you would
scream bloody murder if somebody would
do to you what you're doing to them you
know I mean every kindergartener is
taught the concept of like the Golden
Rule and doing unto others you know but
within our political process you know it
just becomes a you know um you know
might and right you know if you have the
power then you have the power to use it
and that's all well and good but
eventually you're going to be in the
minority and you know you're going to
get good and hard whatever you gave to
somebody else
and I think the challenge is you know if
you don't have folks who are thinking of
that long term if they're not thinking
past the end of the month or the year or
this election cycle you know then
there's no inherent disciplining
mechanism to say well maybe don't pick
up the thing that's just lying right in
front of you um because you know of what
that effect will be on our broader
system but when you don't have
individuals who care about that when you
know everything is shortsighted and well
you know if you're run out of town run
out of DC on a rail you can always pick
up a nice you know kind of cable network
gig uh or you know start your own
company selling you know Sandra de o
Conor bobbleheads or you know you know
beat pills that's going to be a very
different incentive structure than that
oriented towards you know thoughtful
long-term governing when you first
learned about Democrats backing uh and
supporting um you know the person who
was trying to primary you and was
ultimately successful in doing that um
who was very far to the right of you
when you first learned about that a did
you feel like a conspiracy theorist like
did that feel too crazy to be true and B
like how did you process that what did
that feel like in that
moment I mean I wasn't surprised I they
yeah um I was surprised that it came
through the Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee that was actually
their first independent expenditure of
the 2022 midterms it's pretty blat right
like they're not even trying to hide it
it didn't come through some you know
kind
of you thing like it was it was blunt uh
paid for by
DCCC
um and I have my own conspiracy theory
behind that that they make it blunt to
basically send the bad signal to you
know Democratic voters in the district
to say Hey you know there's really no
competitive Democratic primaries you can
vote in either now I I don't think that
had a large impact but you know yeah it
you know I think I called it
sanctimonious on uh um on you
know CNN of just like again like what do
you actually believe and and what you
believe you know be willing to be held
consistent to it so it I should put it
this way very few things that happened
while I was in Congress came as a
surprise to me in terms of me just
objectively being like I can't believe
this is happening so many times where I
would look at you know the you know
possible kind of decision trees and
events and I was like you know what is
probably the least inspiring or the
dumbest or the um the outcome that would
make me say yeah that feels about right
that ended up being the outcome nine
times out of ten so a lot of my worst
assumptions or worst predictions um or
just you know most uh my my lowest
estimation assumptions ended up being
affirmed but I was rarely surprised you
know it's it's still it's still
happening and you that's probably the
the right approach is to just assume the
you know adopt a sort of uh strategic
cynicism because you you will be proven
right when it comes to electoral
politics at this level like the the
latest example of that that struck me
was our colleague Matt Welch uh wrote an
article about uh kind of the third-
party challenges that are likely to
appear this cycle between RFK and the
libertarian party and uh the No Labels
group uh there there's very likely going
to be a a sizable percentage of Voters
um that are that are voting for neither
Trump or Biden possibly you know
covering the spread and that's got these
that's got the Democratic party and
probably the Republican party to
panicked and their surrogates are
engaging in these kinds of behaviors
they're trying to uh you know one of the
uh uh he Matt describes uh a vicious
level of interest in the the No Labels
party there's these tactics that third
party Watchers are very uh familiar with
you know denying ballot access engaging
in
lawfare the normal you know uh routes of
of political uh running uh political ads
um so it is more of this like kind of
undermining democracy to supposedly
protect democracy um I'm reading a book
right now that was recommended by one of
our listeners by Emily Finley about this
concept she calls democratism where
which is more of a romanticized version
of democracy that isn't just a mechanism
for selecting political leaders but is
actually an ideology that leads to
certain social outcomes so I I guess my
my question for you is is there any
antidote to that kind of EST
establishmentarianism that that uh do
you think that first of all I guess do
you think that's real and B can it be
contained are there any methods to
counteract that no I mean to me the the
strongest method is is having having
trusted objective folks who can look at
a situation and just say okay you know
Democrats are railing about about Jerry
mandering and how you know it's you know
the Republicans are being evil down in
Texas that so defend what you guys are
doing in Illinois defending what you're
doing in New York right like I think it
it needs to be called out it needs to be
pointed out um you know I it cracks me
up the amount of times where again um
everything is the most important this
time is different you know we uh uh we
need to throw the rules out the window
um up and until the time where we want
those rules back because they protect us
like up and until the next time is even
worse and now trust us now I mean if you
look at the way in which um you
President Biden every single time he
wants to blame Republicans for something
it's always magga Republicans it's
always extreme magga Republicans it
could be you know Susan Collins and Mitt
Romney you know and they are you know
extreme magga Republicans um and I think
that is certainly not helpful um It
undercuts Whatever argument and I think
just drives us back into a a cynical
polarization where you know you don't
feel like you're going to have a home
but boy is it more comfortable to you
know at least be in one shelter or the
other than in the middle in the
wilderness or yeah I mean it hearkens
back to the your farewell speech where
you're uh quoting Yates and saying like
the center is you know having trouble
holding under those conditions I guess
to to wrap us up maybe you could give us
an optimistic vision for escape from
that like what is your vision of a
GOP and maybe even a Democratic party
that uh is looks different from how it
does right now like what what is the the
GOP that Peter Meyer would like to see
take us into you know really starting a
new American Century yeah I to me that
party is one where you can look at a
republican run City you can look at a
republican Run State and say gosh that
kind of seems like a place I want to
live right where folks are moving and
voting with their feet um you know
they're already doing that the amount of
outflows from California to Florida is
telling you know but having more
opportunities to see policies in action
so we remove the the the rhetorical you
know dependence on on who can make an
argument and get to well what has been
demonstrated to work right I think by
grounding um our our policy discussions
with communities focusing on those
outcomes you know it improves trust it
improves confidence when you have
subsidiarity right you have lower levels
of government that folks can get engaged
with then they feel they have a voice
then they don't feel like what is
happening is something happening to them
but something that they are a part of
that is it is a government of by and for
the people but that requires the right
structure that requires the right setup
it requires you know conservatives
getting back to a fundamental idea a of
conserving the values of the founding
and conserving the principles of the
Constitution right I think it's behind a
lot of the fears a lot of the
frustrations and a lot of the anger on
the Republican party today but it's all
about giving it a direction you know
that Rocket Fuel uh can take you to the
Moon with the right nozzle or you can
blow up on the Launchpad um and so you
know we have the fuel we need the nozzle
and we can go
far Peter Meyer thank you very much for
talking with us today I appreciate the
time this has been fun yeah it's been
wonderful thank
you thanks for listening to just asking
questions these conversations appear on
reason's YouTube channel and the just
asking questions podcast feed every
Thursday subscribe wherever you get your
podcast and please rate and review the
show